was geht es halt so was machst du so
leute herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video wie ihr alle wisst habe ich die
zweieinhalb jahre in denen ich für
weniger aber das hat wirklich nichts
anderes gemacht als mit wissenschaftlich
fundierten methoden möglichst
investigativ und fundiert und wirklich
belegt und wirklich experimentell
herausfinden wie ich auf die beste und
effizienteste art und weise wie das
gesicht möglichst witzig verunstalten
kann das wirklich die leute bezahlen
wenn man leute dafür dass zu machen und
gucken wir mal womit die so rum kommt
und zwar auf fall war das ist eine seite
auf der man visual effects menschen und
aufträge geben kann und sie machen das
dann übers internet ich probier's mal
unter den kategorien video editing und
visual effects das müsste eigentlich
beiden sinnvollsten sein können das soll
heraussuchen und die fangen hier bei
fünf euro an es gibt aber auch leute die
neben hier 1000 euro alter und was wir
jetzt machen ist wie beauftragen ein für
wenig für mittel und für viel geld damit
liebes gesicht möglichst lustig zu
verunstalten und er kommt einfach mal ob
die an meine jahrelange expertise
überhaupt dran kommen oder ob die
komplett ran karten letzte suchen als
aller erstes mal jemanden der hier
zwischen null und fünf euro will nimmt
ja video views auf youtube experience
gut jetzt mal einen mittleren
preisklasse 10 bis 20 euro
der klingt doch gut halb will rock you
and raw power ranger das interessant und
der klingt doch gut er hat hier ein
allgemein hellen drauf der kann man
sicherlich regis gesicht schön verzehren
alter wenn er dann als auch er selber
war es mal geht das ist echt krank und
jetzt für die gut also ist das jetzt gar
nicht ausgeben werden der ist sie ganz
gut aus aber um 50 euro alle ich weiß ja
nicht nur ihm ins gesicht zu verzehren
die professional visual effects ja der
ist doch geil auf 35 euro kann es ja
schon rausgehauen hat
[Musik]
bruder dafür sich auf jeden fall 35 euro
ist ja klar und kaufen letzte gast der
hier raus ballert für 35 euro 54
sekunden clip alle wir jetzt mal gucken
was hier herum kommt wir gehen jetzt mal
zudem für den medienpreis hier mal
schauen was der so raus heute wirklich
die punkte mit seiner arena nahm ihr der
sohn eingeflogen kommt alle da bin ich
echt mal gespannt was der so raushaut
zudem habe ich jetzt auch eine
beschreibung geschrieben einfach die von
dem typen der vorrang kopiert hey hier
sind kipp von deutschland über kannst du
bitte sein gesicht verzerrt auf eine
witzige art und weise so jetzt noch mal
welche von den günstigeren raus also any
video editing und after effects werk mal
gucken was ja schon hier geleistet hat
alles gleich stößt mir einmal ins
abenteuer continue mit 504 auftrag
travis nicht wirklich zu verzerren mal
gucken habt ihr an mein level der
verzerrung überhaupt dran kommen
überhaupt überhaupt diese hilfe
er ist der profi fertigungs liegt
überhaupt an tanzen können das dauert
jetzt zwei drei tage bis dahin gucken
wenn man wie ich einen dieser drei clips
bearbeiten kann
normalerweise mache ich einen schnitt
und damit auch das verzehren immer in
premiere pro das ist ein schnitt aber
heute ich konkurriere gegen die
absoluten profis heute benutze ich
nachts effekt wirkt jedes detail von
regis nicht verunstalten kann
okay wir haben die dateien effekt bietet
wirklich ein großes arsenal an
verzierungen und unverstellt und
beratungstools soll spiel gibt es eine
komplett eigene kategorie no für fans
herum oder gibt es den pc verkrümmung
eckpunkte verschiedenen gibt der
verkrümmung komplexe wellen allahs nicht
gehört und leute ihr kennt den guten
alten strudel findet man meist ein auge
nach links haus ziehen ein bisschen das
sind die funktionen seiner nase dran
ja nase nach oben kommt immer gut und
den mund den kammern noch nach unten
bewegen so dass er so ein bisschen also
hasen zahlenmäßig kriegt es ist so geil
leute hier sich träge auf jedem
veräußert würden massiv hilfe benötigen
wir kommen das ganze jetzt mal an und
gucken ich weiß nicht leute ob die damit
halten können ich weiß es wirklich nicht
[Musik]
dieser frage ist einfach mein leben das
waren alle zwei jahre meines lebens so
werden jetzt einmal um redeten sich zu
der maske umgezogen und jetzt können wir
hier einmal den inhalt basierte
füllungen verkauf machen
ok mal gucken was jetzt dabei
herumgekommen ist auf diesem wunderbaren
[Musik]
so etwas geht bekommen sie sogar mal ein
video portrait drei tage später so
einige tage vergangen regierung jetzt
mal was die leute abgeliefert haben und
wir sehen sie schon an der vorschau alle
dass wir sie richtig gruselig wir
schalten direkt mit dem günstigsten
diese augen schön drauf gecheckt den
mund schön projekt schon seine rüben
richtig groß gemacht und dann da dafür
für sowas hatte ich gern sechs euro das
hat sechs euro gekürzt hat also echt
stark ein weiteres mal raus gehauen und
dann muss man sagen toll gemacht mich
ich glaube er hat wenn ich nicht im
bilde da hier turbulentes versetzen
gemacht und dann eine maske umgezogen
das kann mir gut vorstellen wie sieht
die sitze sind ja schön aus ich muss
sagen mit der preiskategorie günstig bin
ich mega happy für sechs euro wird die
letzten beiden okay let's go hier für 14
euro 12 haferbrei maxi ist ein süßer 12
bei den sexy ist
[Musik]
er hat alba zum ton animiert was ist das
denn alle gehört ich habe richtig viel
spaß das war mir auch auf jeden fall 14
euro werden muss man voll stadt für
diesen drei clubs habe jetzt einfach
schon 26 euro ausgegeben ja mein alter
so das nächste in der mittelklasse kommt
jetzt hier für 16 euro vom imran wie ihr
vater so naja es ist hier schon für 15
euro kann man hier schon erwarten dass
das die leute dieses zeug so richtig zum
ton animieren
es muss allerdings sagen ich fand das so
vor ein bisschen witzig aber ist schon
okay jetzt kommt es absolut aller
spannendste ja für 36 euro für so einen
kurzen effekt alle linien angespannt aus
der so der wirt hat muss aber vorstellen
sechs euro für keine ahnung wie lange
man so braucht für so ein ding
vielleicht fünf minuten nicht mal oder
vielleicht schon krass dafür 36 euro zu
kriegen arbeit hat mir auch drei vier
versionen geschickt dementsprechend er
hat die live anschauen was der so
abgeliefert hat jetzt mit dem ersten
[Musik]
was war das können wir das mal
ansprechen weil also die kanten sind
jetzt hier ein bisschen abgeschnitten
ja man kann noch so in petto hat okay
hier fällt schon der 2 ja geil ich
glaube auch ihr turbulentes versetzen
problems versetzen heißt effekt und dann
hat eine maske drüber gemacht damit man
sie nur sein gesicht versetzt wird bin
ich weiß wenn ich die maske hier
man sieht dass die maske hier hart war
und keine weiche kannte hatte da hätte
man noch eine weiche kannte machen
können aber es wird ja geil also das
heißt der erste und jetzt der letzte den
hat er später auch dann quasi als
finalen gh welt der wieder weggeschickt
hat das heißt das ist seiner meinung
nach der beste mal gucken was er so
herausgeholt hat ich habe das gefühl
dass waren wir gleich noch ein bisschen
zauberei ausgearbeitet top-level ich
jetzt ist ja viel frage finde ich dass
ich finde das teuerste nicht am
witzigsten das tut mir leid also die
hatte schon geil gemacht hat auch
mehrere versionen geliefert also top
service auf jeden fall
der war auch am allerschnellsten muss
man sagen der waren alle schnell sind
dass die flotte rausgeballert ich muss
aber ganz ehrlich sagen ja dass ich hier
vom cap design wobei vielleicht
vielleicht langsamer als erster ist aber
ich fand das absolut gruselig was er
gemacht hat dass er drei wie so richtig
schön gestalteten muss man einfach sagen
stark und ich fand auch den bruder ja
für den fisch 12 mir ist es immer da
wird sich immer noch darüber lachen wie
geil
ja also ich glaube der bruder hat
gewonnen dass ihr mal hier hat der preis
ist nicht mal unbedingt so was zu sagen
weil ich finde jetzt auch die günstigen
sache die finde ich auch mega geil finde
ich genauso witzig wie das teuerste hier
aber man muss sagen der hat mehrere
versionen geliefert und war am
schnellsten
dementsprechend hat sich sehr gelohnt
man macht auf jeden fall mindestens
genauso spaß wie ihres gesichts selbert
jetzt werden diese videos von den
anderen anzuschauen
ja gut es ist das hat schon ein bisschen
was sie selber zu veranstalten das
natürlich noch mal ein anderes level
aber dass alle leute
ja ja so was man wäre dadurch etwa 80
euro wenn man zusammenhält rausgeballert
wofür diese dumm clips aber es war es
komplett wird und wir ja auch schneidend
werden möchte dann habe ich etwas für
euch und zwar meinen schnittkurs das
sind zwei stunden videomaterial wo ich
mega geil gegliedert alle einzelnen
steps von premiere pro erklärter wie man
eben das schneiden lernens in dem kurs
lernen mega schnell alles was die
meisten jemals brauchen werden also also
ohne witz man könnte nur mit dem kurs
vor dem kompletten anfänger zur ews
karte also das was ich bei rewe
geschnitten habe das hatte ich alles mit
dem kurs sie machen können er geht noch
weiter mit alpha masken und farbe arbeit
bleibt schon mal reingehört den kurs
nicht mehr beschreibung und dann wenn
ihr mich auf dieser reise begleiten
möchte dann abonniert mich auf instagram
der post die regelmäßig bilder und
abonniert mich natürlich auch auf
youtube und dann sehen uns beim nächsten
video wieder ganz gut
[Musik]